[Musique]
le retour de l'Amérique promet le
gouverneur de la Floride qui a lancé
officiellement sa campagne
présidentielle en fait ce que vous venez
de voir il a publié sur Twitter
peut-être deux heures avant l'heure
prévue de cette fameuse rencontre dans
l'espace Twitter heureusement qui a fait
ça parce que le reste était complètement
raté puisque ça a commencé avec beaucoup
de retard cet entretien entre Elon Musk
et lui bon alors est-ce que ça va
laisser des conséquences de cette
va-t-elle un lancement historique alors
je joins notre correspondante aux
États-Unis à dévoiler ce qui justement à
Miami bonsoir Azeb
bonsoir Marie et Daniel Marien
professeur en sciences politiques à la
université
c'était tout un ratage Daniel Marien que
ce lancement sur Twitter ou non
au début d'une émission comme ça c'est
l'autre les gens se glissent sur
domicile et puis s'il y a des retages
c'est possible que beaucoup de gens qui
soient décroché
néanmoins vous savez j'écoutais par la
suite le dialogue c'était pas une
mauvaise idée pour le gouvernement de
faire ça parce que c'était dans un
milieu clos c'est-à-dire un milieu où on
est des gens de droite
l'animateur est de droite et il y a pas
de contestation des faits souvent
discutables que des essais affirmation
de fait souvent discutable que le
gouverneur fait alors c'était
effectif je pense dans ce sens là comme
étant écouté comédien ont perduré dans
le au travers des professeurs je sais
pas encore en fait moi quand je suis
allé juste avant l'émission ça tournait
autour de ça quelques milles présence à
ce moment-là mais pas se vanter qu'à un
moment donné il y en a eu 500 000 mais
si ça marchait pas et vous AVEVE jamais
vous montrer la réaction qui est arrivée
sur Twitter très rapidement bah c'est ça
les réseaux sociaux c'est instantané
Elon Musk avec Monsieur De Santis échec
au lancement une fusée qui s'écrase en
arrière alors que retenez-vous de ce
lancement voisin
écoutez cette très belle commencé comme
vous l'avez dit ses 20 minutes et pour
Elon Musk c'est un deuxième lancement
qui rate parce qu'il avait tenté de
lancer une fusée à son projet n'avait
pas marché mais quand même il y avait
300000 personnes j'ai pu quand même
écouter la conversation pendant une
heure il y avait quelque chose de très
simple et sincère si vous voulez les
questions évidemment ont été peut-être
préparés d'avance mais on sentait
vraiment qu'il y avait une spontanéité
dans les réponses c'était une façon
finalement des démystifier en fait qui
est ronde de Santis qu'est-ce qu'il
pense vraiment sur plusieurs enjeux donc
il a eu l'occasion si vous voulez de
s'expliquer sur plusieurs dossiers qui
sont quand même controversés aux
États-Unis
dans un instant mais peut-être qu'on
peut boire une autre image de la
réaction
instantanée de Donald Trump sur son
réseau social si on peut le voir c'est
on va écouter c'est un plein son on va
l'écouter
[Musique]
un peu de dessiner dans cette courte
vidéo je vois sur l'avait vu Daniel
Marien parce que au fond c'était des
alliés de Trump et des
centises cautionnellement puis
aujourd'hui deviennent des adversaires
où il se met beaucoup entre guillemets
alors là je vois que Monsieur Trump est
Monsieur de santé sur sérieux et qu'il
ne laisse pas passer en occasion de
cogner dessus alors voilà ça va être ça
va être intéressant de voir parce que
Monsieur de santé finalement il fait le
même genre de politique en termes de
projet de société ce même genre de
politique
populiste autoritaire et
en fait il veut faire du dropis mais
sans faire propre à l'entrain de se
défend et bien entendu Trump même dans
les sondages c'est vrai que après la
réélection au poste de gouverneur de
Monsieur decentis en novembre dernier
Monsieur De Santis était en avance sur
Donald Trump parmi les républicains mais
bien avant qu'il y ait eu de dépôt
monsieur Trump avait repris l’avance et
voilà Monsieur Trump il est c'est un
communicateur qui
est très efficace pour une certaine
catégorie de la population et ça va être
difficile pour Monsieur De Santis de
d'aller chercher des électeurs à
Monsieur Trump
le donner sondage dans un est retenu un
de CNN
53% en faveur de Monsieur Trump 26% en
faveur de Monsieur De Santis mais il y a
quand même de longs mois de campagne à
venir
dans ce que vous entendez de descente
misant sur son bilan de gouverneur de la
Floride avec des enjeux très
conservateurs est-ce qu'il a des chances
de gruger des voix ou des intentions de
vote du côté de Trump
[Musique]
antichois donc il revient un peu là
dessus mais là De Santis avec ses
récents les restants qui l'a signé et
risque quand même de gruger les votes
donc c'est encore comme vous l'avez dit
trop tôt là pour voir à quel point en
fait il va remonter dans les sondages
quoi qu'il arrive Daniel Marien est-ce
que descente mise sur une victoire
maintenant où est cette île d'être le
principal candidat républicain dès que
Trump est détrôné que ce soit au
primaire à l'élection ou plutôt parce
que Trump est quand même perdant et a
perdu trois dans trois instances
électorale alors que de santé se
présentent comme un grand vainqueur
lui gagne il peut gagner cette diffusion
aux défaites de Monsieur Trump en 2020
et au défait des candidats durant en
2022 des candidats qui avaient été
approuvés ou appuyés par Donald Trump je
veux revenir sur la question de
l'avortement il faut comprendre que le
dessus se positionner à droite de
Monsieur Trump sur l'avortement sur
l'avortement monsieur Trump ménage la
chèvre et de chou monsieur de santé
celui c'est pas plus que 6 semaines et
il faut comprendre que six semaines
interdire l'avortement apprécier ce même
c'est en fait en pratique interdire
l'avortement tout court parce que c'est
pas possible en général d'avoir un
avortement seulement après 6 semaines de
la grossesse ça prend d'abord trois
semaines pour se rendre compte qu'on est
enceinte et puis pour prendre des
rendez-vous à la clinique en Floride la
moyenne d'attente c'est 3 semaines alors
c'est fini alors là il faudrait aller
dans un autre état là ça montre la
dureté de Monsieur Trump et la dame
auquel s'adressait
en Floride parfaitement raison il est
très dur sa politique est très à droite
justement sur le sur la question de
l'avortement et Madame Élie elle autre
candidate mais préfèrent dans les
sondages seul femme candidate jusqu'à
maintenant en tout cas semble dire que
elle elle ferait adoptée d'interdiction
nationale ou fédéral contrairement à la
décision de la Cour suprême en juin
dernier qui renvoyait ça aux différents
états est-ce que ça va être un débat
important entre républicains cette
question là
oui c'est un dossier qui revient parce
qu'ils veulent tous récupérer si vous
voulez la droite religieuse même Mike
pence aujourd'hui s'est exprimé sur la
candidature de loin de Saltis en disant
que bon peut-être qu'on a besoin d'un
nouveau leader que les républicains ont
besoin d'un nouveau leader et sentis en
fait son avantage sur Donald Trump ici
Anne-Marie c'est qu'il a 44 ans il est
jeune et beaucoup de républicains
veulent que si jamais il est évidemment
il remporte l'investiture qui puisse
faire un second mandat alors que Donald
Trump a son âge il ne restait pas de
faire à ce moment-là également loin de
saint-cy c'est présenté comme le
candidat il n'y a pas vraiment de drame
on sait que dans notre chambre il suit
toutes ces batailles judiciaires là il y
en a tellement que les républicains ne
savent plus vraiment où mettre la tête
se présente un peu comme le candidat
propre on sait ce qu'il veut on sait ce
quoi y croient donc là-dessus je pense
qu'il risque quand même d'avoir du
soutien mais dans notre chambre reste
extrêmement populaire ici on a parlé
beaucoup de gens les Floridiens ils
disent que c'est vraiment ils aiment
dans notre chambre et Ran aussi ça
récente loi sur l'immigration n'est pas
du tout populaire surtout dans la
population latino qui est quand même
celle qui avait toujours voté pour lui
parce qu'il divise maintenant les
migrants sans papier il les criminalise
littéralement et même les employeurs
ceux qui les emploie risque également
d'être criminalisés donc ça c'est une
loi qui est pas très populaire donc à
suivre évidemment à suivre évidemment il
reste 10 secondes monsieur Merien
conclusion les règles les règles
d'attribution des délégués la Conférence
nationale de républicaine vont favoriser
monsieur Trump c'est un winner Takor
system alors Monsieur Trump 40% des
votes aura tous les délégués de la
plupart des États et ça c'est l'avantage
de Saint-Esprit
on aime beaucoup vous parler et AZ bien
sûr également merci à tous les deux en
Floride depuis la Floride bonne soirée
au revoir
pour voir nos émissions